I believe your day as an entrepreneur is a
pure reflection of your morning rituals.
How you start your day will determine the
type of day you're going to end up having.
So, one of the most common questions people
ask is, "Pat, I want to know how your day
starts.
What do you do in the morning?
What time do you wake up.
What time do you do this?
What time do you do that?"
So instead of just telling you what I do,
I'll share with you exactly what I do in the
morning when I wake up.
I also went and got a list of people that
I like, how they start their day to give you
some value and give them some love on their
morning rituals.
And this is all entrepreneurs.
And by the way, I want to tell you something
here for you to keep in mind.
You can't wing this area.
This is not an area for you to wing.
It's very simple.
This is not an area for you to wing, because
think about it this way.
Everything is by momentum throughout the day.
It's all about momentum.
So every day is a mountain.
Every single day is a mountain.
This is a mountain here, so meaning you wake
up in the morning and the higher the mountain
goes, the more excited your day starts, the
more the snowball gets thicker and thicker
and thicker, the bigger it gets.
Right?
So you sleep, you're ready, boom you're day
starts, boom boom boom boom, great day.
If you don't have a good start, it's a small
mountain.
So you don't have a lot of time to create
momentum.
It is very important on how you start your
days in the morning.
So, not everybody does the same.
A lot of people have different types of things
they do.
Some are single, some are married, some have
kids, some don't have kids, so you have to
figure out something that works for you, regardless,
regardless.
One of the most common things I hear from
a lot of people is, you know, for me, I have
to wake up at 10:00 in the morning because
I need to do this, this, that.
If you don't get your morning ritual down,
and you have any desire to compete as an entrepreneur,
you are toast.
If you think you're going to be able to compete
with the rest of the guys in the world of
business.
So let's go through a few of them here.
The first one, I want to give some love to
Gary Vee.
Here's what I like what Gary Vee says on his
morning ritual.
He wakes up at 6:00 AM, reads the new in the
bathroom [something I do as well], and before
leaving the house he hugs his kids for five
minutes and calls a family member while driving.
I like that.
Hugs his kids for five minutes and calls a
family member while driving.
Gary, props to you for doing that.
Tony Robbins.
Tony Robbins has a very good ritual.
He doesn't have a specific time that he wakes
up, because of the traveling that he does.
He may be in Europe, he may be here, so he
doesn't have an "I wake up exactly at 4:45
or 5:50" or whatever.
He doesn't have that.
So he doesn't have a time for that.
He wakes up, he does a cold plunge, submerge
for a full minute, under water, cold, cold
water, if you've ever done one of these cold
dips, is what he does, and the primes of his
days, what he calls the primes of his days,
three things.
One, he has a breaking exercise that he does.
If you see it, it's a very -- if you haven't
seen the Tony Robbins documentary, I highly
recommend you watch the Tony Robbins documentary.
I don't even know what it's called.
but I do know if you go on Netflix, and you
type in Tony Robbins documentary, it will
come up.
I highly recommend you watch it.
It's solid.
It shows how some of his events are.
It's "I'm Not Your Guru."
That's what the documentary is called.
Phenomenal.
And you kind of see a day of his life from
what it looks like.
But the prime of his day he has his breathing
exercise, you'll see how he does it.
You may not do it, but that's his.
Expressing gratitude, and prayer.
He's big on prayer, on what he does, which
is pretty interesting.
His day is probably one of the most energetic
people around the world that if you go to
his convention, you see him with his five,
10,000 people that he has.
Everybody is fired up, because his energy
gets everybody else fired up.
You have more of a possibility of impacting
people's lives if your energy is higher.
Morning ritual is purely an energy game is
what you've got to keep in mind.
Zuckerberg.
Let's see what Zuckerberg does.
This is a guy that's worth 40 some billion,
somewhere around there.
He wakes up at 8:00 a.m.
Interesting.
Not a lot -- you hear 5:00, he's an 8:00 a.m-er.
When he hasn't been working all night, so
he's a guy that works all night til 2:00,
3:00 in the morning, but he wakes up at 8:00
a.m.
He wears the exact same shirt every single
day because he doesn't want to spend a lot
of time thinking about what to wear, and so
that's what he does.
Jack Dorsey, founder of Twitter and Square.
He wakes up at 5:30 to meditate, followed
by a six-mile jog.
Pretty intense.
Richard Branson, from Virgin group.
He is generally on his island.
He swims around the island or goes kite surfing
it it's windy.
He then plays tennis before sitting down for
a healthy breakfast.
He doesn't have a set time when he wakes up;
he leaves his curtains open and it's where
exactly the sun rises.
He says, when the sun rises, the light wakes
me up.
So he doesn't have an alarm clock, but typically
the sun rises at 5:45, 6:00 in the morning.
Simon Cowell -- we don't know what time he
wakes up.
He may be waking up about 11:00 in the morning
but he does say what he does in the morning.
He resets the snooze button twice, before
being served a breakfast of hot water with
lemon, papaya juice with lime, oatmeal, tea,
and three smoothies.
Pretty specific.
And knowing his personality, I can actually
see him doing that every single day.
Tory Burch, the designer.
She's worth around a billion, a little shy
of a billion dollars.
Wakes up at 5:45 a.m., immediately checks
her work emails, gets her three boys out of
bed and takes a 45 minute exercise such as
a quick walk.
Now that's her routine.
Let me tell you what I do when I wake up in
the morning.
Okay.
So, before I tell you what I do when I wake
up in the morning, you've got to keep in mind,
I have three kids all under the age of five.
I'm married, I have three kids all under the
age of five, I run a company with a ton of
employees and thousands of agents around the
country selling insurance, annuities, and
investment products.
The company is called PHP Agency.
Now that's what I do as a business, right?
So, one of the things for me, just a couple
of months back, three, four, five months back,
my dad -- if there's one thing my dad will
not hesitate to do -- my dad will pull me
aside and he'll say, "Hey, Mr. Body Builder.
What happened to your six-pack?
Now you have a one-pack."
He has no filters.
If you're out of shape, he'll tell you.
Okay, he's good with the ladies; he won't
tell that to the ladies, but he will tell
me, if I"m out of shape, he'll tell me.
Now I love that because I'd rather have the
truth than you trying to make me feel good
as a father, as a mentor.
So I get on the scale, I weigh 256 is what
I weigh.
I've never weighed 256 before.
The moment I noticed myself weighing 256,
my energy goes high, my energy goes low, and
this was right around when the baby was born.
And when a baby is born, you're doing two
hours of sleep, you're waking up and doing
all this other stuff.
No matter what happens, I feel it.
The moment I feel the energy dropping, the
moment I feel it, I know, because I can't
hang till 10:00 11:00 if I'm starting early.
I know that.
And my business requires me to hang for a
long time because it requires that I have
a lot of energy.
So there is a formula for every single person.
This isn't something - you need to ask yourself
how is your energy in the morning, and how
is your energy in the afternoon.
And can you hang longer, or by 5:00, 6:00,
you're already tired.
Keep in mind, your competitors wake up typically
earlier than you, and they are able to last
longer than you.
That's the only reason they're growing faster
than you and having a bigger business than
you, whatever type of a business they have
in place.
That is if you're competitive.
Here's my morning.
I wake up generally at 4:30 - 4:45 a.m., and
have training sessions at 5:00.
If I have a training session with my trainers
at 6:00, I'm up 5:15.
This morning I had a training session at 6:00;
I can no longer help myself.
It's a 4:45 wake up.
At 4:45 I wake up, I'll check my email, I'll
go through all the information that I have
on my email, I'll typically listen to an audio
book, while I'm driving or walking around.
I will do my daily affirmations on what I
tell myself.
It's been one of my rituals for a long, long
time.
I have my affirmations laminated all over
the wall.
They are all over my shower wall, everywhere
on what I tell myself.
Then I go to the gym.
I do my routine, I do my workout in the morning,
weights.
Right after that, one of the things that I've
been doing recently that I love, let me tell
you, this is a very fascinating thing, if
you have the luxury of doing this.
I'm 6'5", 240, so my back and my knees feel
it a lot, especially when I was in the Army,
we used to ruck march, with 50 pound backpacks.
It's what we used to do, right?
So, cryotherapy, is something I've started
doing recently.
You literally stand there, with no shirt on,
no clothes on, and you stand there, and this
thing starts and it goes all the way down
to minus 240.
And the system I use -- there are many different
ones, these machines run around $100,000 - it
goes to minus 240 for three minutes.
By the time you're done, what happens to the
blood, the entire body, is flexible.
It feels like a million bucks, and your body
gets shocked, is what it does.
Now I do this at 6:00 in the morning, so it
works very, very effectively.
If you can do that at your gym, it's great.
Even if you do it once a week, I highly recommend
it for you to try cryotherapy.
A good breakfast, you have to have a good
breakfast, because that's your gas tank.
So remember, if you go and do 10 miles, 20
miles, 200 miles in your car, you need to
go to a gas station.
Breakfast meals are your gas stations.
You need to go fill up the tank.
Then I do my thinking.
These are the times that I do my thinking,
I do my strategy sessions.
I do my ideation.
I think about what I'm working on, my next
project, what needs help, what needs to be
improved.
Who do I need to call, what is my conversation
going to sound like, what am I going to do
with this, what am I going to do with that,
so it's thinking.
A lot of thinking and strategy.
And praying, definitely praying and meditating,
catching up on news.
If my kids wake up early, they'll typically
wake up at 6:45ish.
I'm typically gone by then, but I play with
them when I get home.
And so that's typical with what my days look
like in the morning.
Now one thing I'm going to tell you to give
you some feedback on -- this is Monday - Saturday
of what my schedule looks like.
Sundays, playday.
Family day, fun day.
You know, there is nothing on Sunday going
on, but me doing whatever I can to have fun
with my kids.
I look forward to Sundays because we have
a great time together.
We play together, we enjoy each other's company.
My wife and I have a great time together.
We either swim in the pool or go and do all
these other things that we do on a Sunday.
There's no set thing on what to do on Sunday.
Sunday is refueling, re-energizing, re-firing
yourself up.
Then at night, there is a lot of preparation
for the week, typically a couple of hours
of preparation for the week.
And then we start the day back up again the
next day.
I typically will do a Facebook Mentions on
Sunday night at 10:00, 9:00 recently to do
some Q&A, with other entrepreneurs from all
around the world, and that's what my week
looks like.
Every week, there's one thing I want to tell
you guys.
If you can't do it every week, I do recommend
it every other week -- especially if your
body is in action, get a massage every other
week, minimum.
Even if it's $60, a dollar a minute, I highly
recommend it.
Get a massage, every other week, minimum.
This body that you have, you and I live in
it, right?
We live in this body.
Let me explain.
We are not the body.
We are the spirit.
We're the mind, right?
We live in this body.
We need to take care of this body, and then
it gives us a lot of miles.
It's like a car.
You buy a car, you know, you drive in the
car, but you're not the car.
I don't know if I'm making any sense.
You're in the car, you're driving the car,
but you're not the car.
The driver dictates how long that car can
last.
You, the body is the car, but your mind, the
heart, we, the spirit, are the driver.
The way you take care of this, this is going
to last a long time.
Now obviously, we cannot unfortunately do
anything at this point with some of the health
things that happen, cancer and all these other
things that you don't have control of.
But you can definitely control energy, weight,
being able to last, being able to do whatever
you can for your body to have more endurance,
more stamina.
All of that is within your control.
And the better you get at doing that, the
longer you can compete.
You know, Warren Buffett is at 70 billion
and one of the things he believes in is buy
and hold -- and one of the things about success
is for you to be able to buy and hold on to
your energy.
The longer your energy lasts, the longer your
competitors are not going to last, because
your competitors are going to get tired.
They're eventually going to make so much money
that their stomach is going to get big, they're
going to have the nice cars, nice house, everything,
and then they're done.
They're done.
But you, if you truly want to play at the
highest level and you want to go five, 10,
15, 20, 30, 40 year play - this is not a three-year,
I'm going to be a millionaire and everyone's
going to say you're a rockstar.
That is boring.
If that's your play and if you think that's
going to feel like a million bucks, it's not.
The play is constantly creating.
The play is constantly having the energy to
come up with new ideas, engaging, sitting
in boardrooms knowing you've got the fire,
you're in charge, you're doing all the right
things -- not all the right decisions all
the time, but you're making the right decisions
51% of the time, and your other guys, your
competitors, are getting tired.
And they're thinking about it.
And they eventually will say phrases like
this -- and this is when you win -- when they
start saying, "Life is not all about success
and money."Ah!
That's an alibi.
They've given up.
You win.
Of course life is not all about money.
If you're saying life is all about money,
it's not.
But life is -- you've got 80 years.
What you do with this 80 years 80-100 years,
whatever your timeline's going to be, that's
the impact you're going to make with the next
generation.
I don't think we're here just for ourselves.
See, it's people that say, "Life isn't all
about money" -- yeah.
You think life is only about you.
I don't think life is all about myself.
I think life is all about what I do for the
next generation.
My example, my value, what I do with my kids,
how I raise my boys, how I raise my daughter,
the way I treat my wife, my family, that dictates
the exact play everyone's going to watch for
the next one.
That's what this means.
So, we need to know that our capacity, the
purpose you have, the impact you can make
in the world is massive, but you need a lot
of energy to do that.
So going back to the morning ritual, you can
do research, there's plenty of research you
can do on different people and what they do.
But one of the most common things everyone
has, is movement of the body, to create a
lot of energy, proper food, proper nutrition
to be able to last a long time, more than
their competitors, just like in sports, just
like in basketball, just like in boxing - what
do they say?
Let's see if you can last 12 rounds.
Let's see how they'll play in the fourth quarter.
Let's see how they're going to do in the third
period when their legs are gone in hockey.
Let's see how they're going to do in stoppage
time in soccer, when they're so tired, everyone's
tired.
Ronaldo recently won the championship -- it's
in the stoppage time, and one of his teammates
scored a goal, he's hurt, that's the moment
you win in business.
The moment you win in the business is when
everybody's gone, when everyone's tired, and
you're still at the office, coming up with
ideas, everybody's disappeared, you're left.
You're the last one standing.
And that's what it's going to take, and you
better have lots of energy and stamina and
endurance, to be able to compete in this world,
in the world of capitalism.
The world of capitalism favors those people
that have high energy, high intensity, and
are willing to sustain that energy for long
periods of time.
And you can do that, because there's a formula
for it.
With that being said, Paul, throw me my favorite
pillow.
Hey, 100,000 subs by August 31st.
100,000 subs, by August 31st.
We're getting a lot of love, we're getting
a lot of people that are helping us out, we're
growing with more subs right now than ever,
we're averaging around 600-700 subs a day;
we need to get to about 1,000, 1500 subs a
day to hit our goal, so if you haven't subscribed
to this channel yet, we believe -- firmly
-- pound for pound, we can go against anybody
on subjects of entrepreneurship on this YouTube
channel, and we firmly believe that.
Very soon we're going to have contributors
from other people that we're going to bring,
entrepreneurs, experts in specific fields,
to also be contributing to this channel, but
this is the number one channel for entrepreneurs,
on YouTube, how-to, not just motivation, how-to,
all aspects of it, so if you haven't subscribed,
please do so, and help us get to 100,000 subs.
[Good catch, Paul.
He played football before.
I'm not going to tell you about the league,
but he did play football before.
And he's done many, many great things for
himself in the world of football.]
So, if you've got questions, comment on the
bottom.
I typically get back to people with questions
that they have, and if you watch this video
all over the Internet, somewhere else, you
can always come back to PatrickBetDavid.com,
and you can find many, many more videos on
our website, especially a new video that we
have on PatrickBetDavid.com that is a real
cool video for you to see.
It's a short film we produced.
Thanks so much everybody, take care, bye bye.